hobbys der nazis wie soll das denn hier
ich will kind ich habe kein risiko
irgendwie zu erkranken warum soll ich
mir den scheiß rennen aber nachdenken
statt quer denken wo die straße zu gehen
soll aber nicht auf mutig
ich möchte keine kommentare zur
[Musik]
jeden montag protestieren tausende quer
durch deutschland ich bin in brackenheim
baden württemberg in die kleine stadt
sind zuletzt bis zu 2000
demonstrantinnen und demonstranten
gekommen und es werden immer mehr woche
für woche gehen menschen hier in
brackenheim auf die straße um gegen die
korona maßnahmen zu demonstrieren wir
wollen wissen was sie antreibt und was
ihre ziele sind wir fallen besonders die
vielen jungen leute auf fabian binder
und nico reichel sind beide 18 sie sind
aus dem 20 autominuten entfernten
kirchheim her gefahren also ich denke
dass jetzt mal kostenpunkt des
schalls ja ich glaub halt nicht alles
was die jugend und zeigt und von den
zahlen her und so die kranken und toten
und das alles müsste vorfeld ständig
leute sterben herzinfarkt man wird
gesagt obwohl die krone haben wir es
wird gesagt es liegt an cholera
gestorben ist ja den gewohnheiten aber
etwas anderen plattform autounfall haben
corona währenddessen kolator deshalb
will sie das nochmal und das heißt ihr
seid ja eigentlich
demgegenüber einfach skeptisch der
regierung ja oder wer ist dagegen der
staat die sagen auch jeden tag etwas
anderes am anfang dieses verhalten ist
gibt keine impfpflicht steht gar nicht
zur debatte jetzt heißt es ja im pflicht
soll eingeführt werden und sonst was ich
habe den eindruck dass viele hier ihr
vertrauen in die politik verloren haben
und alles an zweifeln was in berlin in
stuttgart oder anderswo beschlossen wird
und
wieso
weil ich einfach meine meinung kund
geben euch mitlaufen möchte und ich
einfach finde dass
das nicht frei entscheiden sollen es
werden möchte das nicht man schauen dass
wir keine nazis keine bösen
menschenwürde auch noch in den medien
gezeigt dass wir rechtsradikalen
verdrängen denn sonst irgendwas aber es
ist das heißt wenn jetzt rechtsradikale
jähriger mit laufen würden wäre es ein
problem für sie oder würden sie kosten
weiter mit laufen jedes heute des glaube
und denken was man möchte ganz klar aber
jeder soll jeden zu leben lassen wer
möchte und also ich hab ich bin nicht
für nazis entgegen also ich bin kein
hatten war dass wir es nicht
haben so lange friedrich ich mich
einfach dass meine meine interessen
vertreten werden vollkommen offen egal
in welche gruppierung diese interessen
auf kritik so ganz üblich sind sich
täglich sodass neben fragen und ich
meinen gleich sollten keine nazis
fahrerkarte nazi parole das sonst
irgendwas
beschrieben werden ganz klar so lustvoll
ehrlich und alle miteinander schön
laufen
ok und das habe ich schon irgendwie noch
keiner demo wurde ich sagen also keine
rechten keine nazis keine
menschen sind ja auch nicht zu erkennen
ja ich stehe allerdings ich wurde mit
der vision teilweise bösartig von
menschen angegangen titeln waren wir
machen geschäfte haben
irgendwelche die syrischen klassischen
größte wert er ja nation hier sei schuld
dass superminis aufhören
ich bin asozial weißmann klingt das
impfen lass und verunglimpft
ja
aber würden sie sicherstellen getan
eindeutig wert in diesem fall
werde einfach dass man einfach selber
drüber nachdenken in sachen hünerfeld
und sie sich gedanken darüber macht was
passiert in der welt momentan offene
zukunft
ich bin doch da wurde schon da er sagen
ich bin ein querträger weiß einfach
[Musik]
ein kamera team und ich werden immer
wieder beschimpft aber auch mit diesen
menschen versuche ich ins gespräch zu
kommen oft vergeblich
allerdings kommen was sind
was
also wer gut ich wollte nur ein
austausch wenn sie sagen lügen presse
aber sie haben wir die möglichkeit mit
uns zu sprechen
für heute war auch eine gegendemo
angekündigt stattgefunden hat sie nicht
aber die spannung im ort spüre ich
deutlich die einen sind wütend auf die
regierung die anderen auf die
demonstranten viele die hier wohnen
fühlen sich belästigt
weiß was für leute da mitlaufen
ja was soll gewaltpotenzial damit drin
steckt was sind das für leute ihrer
meinung nach ist ein faschist dritte weg
hat
europawoche flyer verteilt und
was der dritte weg ist allseits bekannt
augen klein spotter eine
neofaschistische
dass sich diese rechtsextreme kleinen
partei gegründet von ehemaligen
npd-mitgliedern unter die demonstranten
gemischt hat bestätigen mir viele hier
an diesem abend geben sie sich nicht zu
erkennen
2000 menschen rund gegen die maßnahmen
auf das problem ist dass sie nicht alle
von fragen sei man viele zug reisten aus
esslingen aus stuttgart aus ludwigsburg
und sonst woher kommen denn dann soll es
irgendwo anders in der pampa ihren sah
ich vertrete ja
auf der freien wiese scheißegal aber
nicht hier durch dort
bei ihnen sind noch stattfindet
erfüllung schrecklich
schritt nichts als praktisch wieso ist
es in den worten hallo da bin ich jetzt
nicht genauer eingehen ich weiß nur dass
in partenheim einander tiefe medizin so
genannte
[Musik]
ich die polizei soll es nicht
es ist das recht von den personen hier
zu hause
einige
sachen die die sage sind ja auch
durchaus richtig aber es ist nicht die
mehrheit
auch in partenheim nicht
wenn ihm entgegen ich was
so wird doch gleich wegen die herren
also für dich stört sie das dass er
stattfindet
wir wollen diese aber nur mal gucken wie
das hier fertig geht wie sie
seit mehr als einem jahr werden jeden
montag corona demo sind partenheim
angemeldet bislang waren sie friedlich
mir fällt auf dass viele über ihre angst
vor impfschäden sprechen dieses junge
paar erzählt mir von freundinnen die
angeblich nach ihrer impfung erkrankt
sein ich habe freunde die es auf 20 war
top gesundes zwei tage nach ihrer
impfungen lag die notaufnahme mit
problem man kennt einfach geschichten
auf beide seiten ich glaube auch
wirklich das büro nach schlimm ist und
dass man den corona krankenhaus liegen
kann das glaube ich wirklich aber ich
hab sie einfach gesehen und eine andere
freundin halbseitige lähmung seit der
impfung nicht mehr weggegangen
ich komme
ja nichts dagegen wenn sie hier und das
ist ja so eine entscheidung und ich
finde jeder sein eigenes ding wir wollen
da er keinen rein reden dass es wird und
wir fangen schon gut das ist impfung
gibt für jeden der angst hat ist es
wirklich gut fühlt ihr euch in der ecke
gedrängt dadurch wenn wir diese meinung
kundtat sie gar nicht mehr man traurig
dass nicht mehr zu sagen und auch
hinsichtlich dass das euch vorgeworfen
wird dass ihr querdenker seit oder
hoffen die leute sagen was sie wolle
passiert euch das
mir persönlich hat noch niemand gesagt
doch meine oma
[Gelächter]
irgendwie dagegen geäußert dass es
schlecht wäre oder oder das mit komplett
dagegen werden wie gesagt das ist für
jeden für jeden kleine eigene
entscheidung aber ich bin 31 halbes
waren wir auch hier weil es halt
eigentlich seine eigene entscheidung
sein sollte und bleiben sollte auch wenn
ich viele sind frage stelle versuche ich
zu verstehen wieso sie hier auf die
straße gehen dann begegne ich eine frau
aus dem nachbarort sie erzählt mir dass
sie hebamme ist wegen der demo kommt sie
mit ihrem auto nicht weg muss warten bis
alle vorbeigegangen sind generell finde
ich es wichtig dass man seine meinung
sagen kann im fernöstlichen menschen das
sind in ordnung aber ich habe mir
wünsche ist nicht aggressiv und ich
empfand es phasenweise sehr aggressiv
zum teil
ja ein großes thema sucht das werden
einen entspannten sommer ein gutes
miteinander wiederkommen finden sie ja
ich finde es schon einmal sehr spannend
und ich finde es ist schon ein
emotionales emotional von der anderen
seite zum teil und das ist schwierig
weil man eigentlich ein ort wo man doch
miteinander vereine war miteinander
chöre gesungen hat und so weiter und ich
finde man muss ich gucken dass man das
wieder gut zusammenbringen das würde ich
mir wünsche ich habe dadurch wünsche
dass sich menschen verlassen weil ich
die betroffenheit kennen von betroffene
familien betroffene schwangere und das
finde ich immer wenn man sie an da ist
an solchen schicksalen
hat man da einmal innerlich eine andere
haltung dazu dass man sich wirklich
aussagen andererseits kann ich es
akzeptieren wenn menschen was ich sagen
möchte sich mit ihm verlasse das ist
auch eine rechte sie haben können und es
muss schon sagen aber es hat susanne
zwei seiten wir sind sie ich hab ich
jetzt nicht unbedingt
das ging wie man sich als ich bin so
hawke und das team verlassen und sich
schützen wollen also das ist voll
berechtigt und ich find's auch wichtig
das sollte sich der risikogruppen sich
impfen lassen um sich zu schützen um so
das risiko einer schweren erkrankung zu
zu nehmen dann aber wissen sie ich bin
relativ jung ich bin sportlich ernähre
mich gesund und es ist aber nicht ein
dass ich ja in gewisser weise dazu
gedrängt werden
wenn man etwas dagegen sagt und es
morgen noch gleichsam ein
rechtsradikale oder gewalt
gab dass man das sage ich mal ernst
genommen wird oder
auch die anderen meinen hört man immer
diskutieren nicht richtig offen hat er
schon immer irgendwas zu sagen wurde das
thema das belastet
da muss man sich ja schon sprache die
musik hingekommen mittlerweile
ja also ich möchte auf jeden fall dass
inzwischen mehr
menschen auf die strassen sich ab
alles mögliche beschimpft als sportler
als als
nazis und
eine faire berichterstattung kommt erst
so in letzter zeit habe ich das gefühl
wie findet ihr das kommt ja aus
brackenheim und
das hier so die lose sie jetzt jeden
montagabend richtig traurig schrecklich
nette haut sondern es ist halt auch
einfach traurig dass so viele menschen
hier stehen und wir hoffen eine diktatur
obwohl das einfach nur wohlstand ist und
luxus dass sie überhaupt das den dörfern
und protestieren dürfen ihr habt durch
jetzt wirklich da hingestellt und gesagt
wir sind mit unseren spielern dienen
entgegen mutig oder habt ihr was die
straße zu gehen und so ein spiel aber
nicht auch mutig aber halt habt ihr euch
sorgen gemacht wo er
eigentlich nicht aber wenn man da so
steht laufen lauter erwachsene männer
also zwei jungen mädels vorbei und rufen
den irgendwelche blöden sachen zu und
pfeifen und tröten so was wie das die
wohl nachdenken dass wir nach ja das wir
nachdenken soll dass wir morgen körbe
aufwerten
so was gespielt haben
bevor sich die würgeser karten und mit
eurem einfach mal laut zu werden noch
nicht immer zu zeigen gegen das was
dahinter passiert
und hat auch einfach mal präsent zu sein
und den hat jetzt also zu zeigen dass
ich es nicht machen können was sie
wollen
sie wollen dass die korona maßnahmen
abgeschafft werden ich habe den eindruck
viele fühlen sich ausgeschlossen und
ungerecht behandelt diese junge frau
will nicht erkannt werden sie schildert
mir sichtlich berührt dass sie bald
ihren job als altenpflegerin verlieren
könnte weil sie sich nicht impfen lassen
will ähnlich geht es auch sina weber
seinen job so und ich habe meine
ausbildung fertig gemacht und ich kriege
ich werde einfach überall abgelehnt
einfach nur aufgrund dadurch dass ich
nicht geimpft bin finde ich nicht
richtig so warum es sich doch eine 3g
bestimmung am arbeitsplatz wie soweit
ich dann abgelehnt wegen der impfung so
verstehe ich einfach nicht und das dafür
stehe ich auch hier oben das einfach zu
vertreten und um zu zeigen hey wir sind
menschen egal wie fragen was für eine
ausbildung gemacht im medizinischen
bereich zahnmedizin zahnmedizinische
fachangestellte und da ich auch die
impfpflicht ab märz und ich habe jetzt
auch schon von einigen gehört
das werden sie sich nicht impfen lassen
ab 15 märz die kündigung darstellt und
das ist auch nicht richtig es ergibt
keinen sinn das ist schikane
das ist einfach ein zwang mich impfen zu
lassen so man fühlt sich schon extrem
aus der gesellschaft ausgeschlossen das
halt alle also dass das alles so
bekämpfen sage ich jetzt mal menschen
die die können jetzt feiern geht oder
ihr okay des clubs sind jetzt aus zu
aber die können auf dem konzert mal oder
sonst irgendwo essen gehen das ist für
uns hat alles nicht drin aber wir haben
die entscheidung getroffen hat zu
bleiben so und dann mal für ein oder
zwei jahre aufs essen gehen zu
verzichten aber dafür stehen wir unseren
mann zu bleiben hat und lassen uns das
unterdrücken von irgendeiner politik
bei der abschließenden kundgebung spüre
ich die menschen sind mit dem
politischen entscheidungen grundsätzlich
unzufrieden und wütend auf die da oben
nach der heutigen corona demonstration
hier in brackenheim habe ich das gefühl
dass es gar nicht den einen grund gibt
weshalb die menschen hier auf die straße
gehen sondern viele verschiedene die
meisten haben sorge vor der impfung und
dass die impfung ihnen schaden könnte
und fordern daher dass es keine
impfpflicht geben soll was aber alle
eint ist dass sie sich von der politik
nicht mehr vertreten fühlen
brackenheim der geburtsort des ersten
bundespräsidenten theodor heuss auf mich
wirkt eher gespalten die stadt hat
banner aufgehängt positioniert sich
gegenüber den demonstranten
es ist eine schweigende mehrheit gegen
eine laute minderheit
[Musik]